في كل عام كانت تبرز عده اسماء كشخصيات
كان لها دور كبير في مجالات عده ربما
اثارت الجدل في مواضيع تتعلق بها هذه
الشخصيات كانت تحت اضاءه لحظات الكبيره في
مسيرتها وعانت من لحظات حرجه في حياتها
هذا العام ثقافيه رياضيا فنيا تقنيا
اقتصاديا وحتى سياسيا كانت الاسماء
البارزه كثيره بتفاصيلها وحكاياتها التي
دفعتها لتكون عين الحدث هذه الشخصيات التي
اخترنا منها ما كانت الاكثر كثيرا وساهمت
لرسم خطوط عريضه لقصصا استحقت واستغرقت
الكثير
[موسيقى]
مع الشهر الاخير من هذا العام كان ليونيل
ميسي اكثر الاشخاص الذين جذبوا الانتباه
في الايام الاخيره من 20 22 رياضيا النجم
الارجنتيني حقق حلمه حلم ملايين
الارجنتينيين ومئات الملايين من عشاق
التانجو حول العالم لتحقيقه كاس العالم
رفقه المنتخب الارجنتين ليون هي صيام
الارجنتين عن اللقب العالمي الاغلى الذي
استمر لسته 36 عاما محققا بطوله الوحيده
التي كانت تنقص مسيرته وتاريخه المليء
بالالقاب
[موسيقى]
من ساعه الرياضه الى ساحه السياسه حيث
تطهى الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه على كل
الاحداث تلك الحرب التي بدات منذ الايام
الاخيره لشهر فبراير الماضي هذه المعارك
الطويله حمله رئيس الاوكراني بلاديمير
يصبح الشخصيه الابر سياسيا هذا العالم فهو
الرجل الذي بقي في كيف ولم يخرج منها رغم
التقدم روسي في بلاده ليس ذلك بل تحول الى
ايقونه بالنسبه شعبه ولي الاوروبيين الذين
نصاروه سياسيا وعسكريا
ليس بسبب فيلم جديد كسر الارقام القياسيه
للايرادات انما بسبب دعوه تشهير التي
رفعها على طليقته بسبب مقال راي زعمت فيه
انها كانت ضحيه لعنف الاسري وراء انها
تقصد الاضرار بالشمعه بدات المحاكمه في
الحادي عشر من ابريل استمرت لسته اسابيع
بعد ذلك العالم حاجه بوضوح لجوني داك
وهيئه المحلفين ايضا التي خلصت في النهايه
الى ان امبيررد شوهت سمعه طليقها وقررت
حصولها على تعويضات بقيمه 15 مليون دولار
امريكي
ومع اجمل طلاقه عالميه الى ازمه طلاق
عربيه في ديسمبر 20 21 وقع طلاق رسميا بين
النجمه شيرين عبد الوهاب وحسام حبيب بعد
ثلاث سنوات من الزواج في بيان نشراته
شيرين تقول في انفصال تم في هدوء ولكن
بدايه 2000 و 2022 تبدا الدراما سلسله من
الجدل من اول العام لاخره فطاره تتهم
شيرين طليقها بانه اشهر مسدس في وجهها
تاره اخرى تدلب تصريحات ناريه ضدها تتهمه
بالاعتداء عليها خلال الاتصال هاتفي لكن
هل انتهت قصتنا هنا تفاصيل جديده عن تعاطي
شيرين وحسام حبيب مخدرات قبل ان تدخل 20
مستشفى النفسي للعلاج وبعد طاعته في
العربيه واسع مع قصتها تصدق شيرين جمهورها
بعقرارها على حسام حبيب من جديد ما قلب
قطاعا كبيرا من جمهورها عليها وتسبب حتى
في دعوات تطالب بمقاطعه اعمالنا
على الجانب التقني اقتصادي وفي سباق الجدل
وتصريحاته فوزوا حتما الى المسك الذي لم
يمر يوما في 20 22 دون ان يكون محور
احاديث العلم قربما الفوضى التي حدثت قبل
وبعد استحواذه على تويتر سببا اساسيا في
هذا الزخرف الملياردير يقدم عرضا
الاستحواذ على تويتر في ايبر الماضي ويقبل
تويتر العرض فيتراجع ماسك عن الصفقه وذلك
بحجه مسؤوليته
عن الحجم الحسابات الوهميه على منصه تويتر
فتقادل منصه ما لك تسلم لكن مع اقتراب
المحاكمه يعيد ماسك تقديمه يستحوذ على
المنصه في اكتوبر ليبدا فصلا جديدا من
التخبط والانتقدات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]